afri toujours de casques bleus ont été
tués hier par les rebelles en république
sont affairés centrafricaine et ce le
jour où la cour constitutionnelle a
proclamé la victoire officielle de
faustin archange touadéra à la
présidentielle peu avant ce scrutin une
coalition de six groupes rebelles
annoncé à une offensive pour empêcher sa
réélection gérant je cite d'aller
marcher sur bangui si les rebelles
mènent des attaques sporadiques
ils font face à la présence de la minus
qu'à la mission onusienne
constitué d'un douze mille casques bleus
la minustah a payé un lourd tribut avec
sept casques bleus tombés au service de
la paix depuis le lancement d attaque
coordonnée et simultanée par la
coalition formée par les anti ballack a
le 3r le mpc et l'upc a lié à l'ancien
président françois bozizé mais elles
restent engagés à poursuivre son mandat
de protection des populations civiles et
de sécurisation des élections et en
direct dans cette édition qu'axa nous si
le président de l'institut international
de gestion des conflits
bon joueur qui excelle aussi merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
arte france c'est la tension du côté de
la centrafrique est ce que la situation
peut dégénérer à quoi est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre ces prochains jours après de
nombreux casques bleus qui ont donc
trouvé la mort je pense qu'il faut
s'attendre à l'accalmie il faut
s'attendre à tout les dynamiques qui
seront mises en place pour ramener la
sérénité la maintenant que le mandat du
président wade a été confirmée par la
conventionnelle et nous pensons que qui
fait face aujourd'hui suite à la
situation qui prévaut à trois défis
majeurs qu'il va falloir remplir pour
pouvoir ramener le calme totalement 56k
et quelle est la valeur de ce double
scrutin la fois présidentielle et
législatives qui a eu lieu en décembre
dernier alors que près de deux électeurs
sur trois ne se sont pas déplacés aux
urnes mais je pense que on entendu pas
mal de critiques sur le fait que toute
la population n'a pas pu voter ce qui
est une réalité si elle n'a pas pu voter
c'est parce que aussi il y a eu des
fausses et qui ont empêché le votant
mais en même temps nous pensons que la
démocratie se considérer fois dans la
douleur je l'avais déjà dit et qu' il
fallait quand même consulter leur insu
sont de la république a maintenant le
président wade rhin en face aux défis de
la consolidation de la paix en se basant
sur plusieurs piliers les faca qu'il
faut renforcer et la justice qui doit
passer et surtout la concertation le
dialogue avec toutes les parties
prenantes et puis aussi dans son défi
c'est pour suivre la rupture qui
l'engagé lors de son premier mandat pour
faire en sorte que les pratiques qui ont
entraîné la situation nous sommes jeudi
à 51 puis celle des pratiques révolues
la rupture dans tous les domaines est
l'élément le plus fondamental pour les
centrafricains
c'est le processus de développement et
de l'autonomisation de la centrafique
dans tous les secteurs économiques de
santé et éducation
je pense que nous disons souvent que la
fin de toute chose vaut mieux que son
commencement
ce dernier mandat qui te rendes a
vraiment de concrétisation et de
transformation de la centrafrique afin
que la transition pour ce fait demain
avec un autre touba qui viennent pas
suite aux élections
vous avez évoqué des
un dialogue comment instaurer un
dialogue avec les attaques qui ont lieu
en ce moment un dialogue entre le
pouvoir donc faustin archange touadéra
et et toutes les parties prenantes de la
coalition rebelle entre les antilles
ballack a entre le 3r tout c'est toutes
ces mouvances alliées notamment à
l'ancien président françois bozizé
comment instaurer un dialogue possible
et efficace
je pense que le dialogue est toujours
nécessaire mais le dialogue n'est pas là
où il ya des stars et c'est pourquoi je
pense que il ya déjà des missions de
bons offices qui sont en cours pour que
les commanditaires ceux qui sont avec
ces rebelles puissent leur demander de
laisser tomber les armes mais le
dialogue commence aussi avec les forces
vives de la nation les hommes politiques
alain structure associative à les
responsables communautaires parce qu'il
est important que ceux qui ont pris des
armes puissent comprendre que ce n'est
pas la majorité des centrafricains que
les différends politiques ne seraient
que papa d âme
les différentes politiques c'est vrai
que sur le plan démocratique et c'est
comme ça qu'il faut faire et nous
pensons que le dialogue est nécessaire
même si aujourd'hui il est difficile il
faut en même temps nous le disons que la
justice passe parce qu'on peut pas
négocier avec des gens qui ont des âmes
mais on peut négocier une fois qu'on a
posé des armes
diallo que tu te bats pour voir quel est
l'objet et de la prise des armes donc un
sens trafic aujourd'hui nous le disons
le montant du présentoir directement
dans qui sera un peu difficile au
redémarrage parce que effectivement il
faut éteindre les feux partout et faire
en sorte que la sécurité puis ce robinet
est que les gens ne soient pas inquiétés
et quand vous allez démarrage combien de
temps il va durer c'est le démarrage ou
dit amanda qui va être difficile au
démarrage mais pour combien de temps à
quoi est-ce qu'il faut vous avez dit au
début de l'interview qu'on va aller vers
l'apaisement mais au bout de vos bout de
combien de temps est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer une sortie de crise dans les
mois ou les où les jours à venir depuis
que faustin archange touadéra a été
confirmée donc un président de la
centrafrique
je pense que celles qui m'avaient que
sans délai les processus doivent
commencer je pense qu'elles sont les
accords ans et tous hutin dans les
contacts à voir avec les différents
partenaires
vous savez il faut en même temps faire
en sorte que pour que l'état républicain
est sidérant son parti que soit solide
il faut que la justice passe donc il
faut tenir les deux en même temps avoir
lajus qui passent de manière
intransigeante et en même temps que
commencer tous ne pas dialoguer je ne
sais par la dure
qu'il faudra mais il faut commencer et
on ne perd pas en commençant tout de
suite tout le processus de concertation
et d'échangés avec les parties prenantes
merci quelques scènes aussi d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le président de l'institut
international de gestion des conflits